vamos a trazar aquí dos rectas esta va a
ser una primer recta que le voy a poner
la recta a b entonces estoy acá es a
estoy acá es b y por acá va una segunda
recta que va digamos más o menos por a
por ahí ya esa recta le voy a llamar la
recta hace de la recta sede entonces
este punto de por acá va a ser ce y este
punto de por acá va a ser de saleh lo
que vamos a suponer de estas dos rectas
es que están en un mismo plano
por ejemplo en esta pantalla que estás
viendo o a lo mejor las dos están en un
papel y además vamos a suponer que estas
dos rectas nunca se intersectan entre sí
vale bueno cuando esto sucede cuando
tenemos dos rectas que nunca se cortan y
son distintas decimos que son rectas
paralelas voy a ponerle por acá
lee las lee
rectas paralelas vale entonces esto lo
podemos pensar como que se mueven en la
misma dirección o lo mejor no podemos
pensar algebraica mente como que tienen
la misma pendiente pero tienen diferente
ordenada al origen si aquí pusiéramos
unos ejes coordenadas un eje xy un eje y
entonces cortarían al eje y en
diferentes lugares vale bueno lo que
quiero pensar es cómo son los ángulos
entre una pareja de rectas paralelas y
otra recta más pero antes de eso déjame
decirte cómo escribir que dos rectas son
paralelas para eso podemos escribir que
ave
ave la recta ave recuerda que arriba
tiene flecha hacia los dos lados es
paralela lo ponemos con una doble raya a
la recta cede esto sería escrito o bien
en el dibujo lo podemos marcar con
flechas que van hacia la misma dirección
aquí pongo una flecha y aquí otra o si
ya utilicé una flecha puedo poner dos
flechas esta recta es paralela a esta de
acá vale bueno ya que sabemos cómo
indicarlo ahora sí lo que quiero hacer
es tomar una tercer recta déjame tomar
una tercera recta de color verde que
atraviese a ambas digamos esta recta de
acá vale esta recta sigue para allá y
para allá y le pondré nombre no nada más
déjame llamarle la recta el vale
entonces la recta l atraviesa las dos
rectas paralelas muy bien a esta recta
que atraviesa oa cualquier recta que
atraviese a dos rectas paralelas se le
conoce como una recta transversal
bersal de sal vale entonces es una recta
transversal a la pareja de rectas
paralelas y lo que quiero hacer es cómo
son los ángulos que hace la recta
transversal con estas dos rectas
paralelas vale por ejemplo una cosa que
sabemos es que este ángulo de acá que
voy a pintar en color rosa este ángulo
de acá es igual a este ángulo de acá
porque son ángulos opuestos por el
vértice sale eso es algo que ya vimos
varias veces de manera similar este
ángulo de acá es opuesto por el vértice
con este ángulo de acá y por lo tanto
miden lo mismo y podríamos hacer
exactamente lo mismo aquí arriba verdad
los podríamos marcar está igual a este y
este igual a este pero lo que me quiero
preguntar es una cosa un poco más
interesante lo que quiero saber es cómo
se compara este ángulo este ángulo voy a
utilizar otro color este ángulo morado
con este ángulo de acá con este ángulo
de acá y si lo piensas tantito pues la
relación es más o menos obvia resulta
que este ángulo siempre es igual a éste
estas dos rectas llevan la misma
dirección y ésta las atraviesa entonces
estos dos ángulos no tendrían por qué
ser diferentes a lo mejor es más claro
en otro dibujo voy a hacer otro dibujo
por acá en color azul en un dibujo donde
las rectas sean horizontales si tengo
estas dos rectas y las atravieso con una
transversal entonces este ángulo este
ángulo de aquí claramente va a medir lo
mismo este ángulo de acá claramente va a
medir lo mismo que éste de por acá ahora
en realidad no voy a poder darte una
demostración de eso porque los
matemáticos a esto lo toman como un
axioma es decir esta es una propiedad
que tiene que ser parte de las cosas que
aceptamos como evidentes para poder
hacer geometría en el plano no quiero
hacerme muchas bolas con eso pero puedes
pensarlo de otras formas por ejemplo si
tomaras un transportador y mides este
ángulo lo que tendrías que hacer es
poner la orilla del transportador aquí
a este el transportador y ver cuando se
este ángulo pero tienes que hacer
básicamente lo mismo de este lado nada
más tienes que trasladar el
transportador para acá
ponerlo por aquí y ver cuánto mide y
como este es paralelo a este debe dar la
misma medida vale bueno esto es más o
menos para entender un poco más porque
funciona déjame regresar para acá vale
entonces este ángulo es igual a este
ángulo de acá este ángulo es igual a
este ángulo de acá eso se conoce como
ángulos correspondientes son ángulos
correspondientes para esta transversal
con respecto a esta recta de paralelas
ya dije así un montón de palabras y este
pues muy rebuscadas pero simplemente
estoy diciendo que este ángulo como le
corresponde este de acá entonces deben
medir lo mismo esos dos se conocen como
ángulos ángulos
a ángulos correspondientes
correspondientes
dientes sale y como este ángulo es igual
este de acá y este es igual al opuesto
por el vértice entonces este ángulo
sería igual a este de acá sale entonces
ya tenemos cuatro ángulos cuatro ángulos
congruentes este este este y este de acá
y de manera similar este ángulo es
correspondiente a este de acá
vale y eso puesto por el vértice con
este de acá entonces tenemos que también
estos cuatro ángulos estos cuatro
ángulos son congruentes vale entonces
tenemos que ángulos correspondientes son
iguales y entonces estos son congruentes
pero eso hace que aparezcan otras
parejas de ángulos que sean congruentes
por ejemplo este de aquí con este de acá
y a esos dos se les conoce como ángulos
alternos internos déjame ponerle nombre
a los ángulos porque si no puede que nos
hagamos bolas a ver este ángulo de acá
se va a llamar a y éste se va a llamar b
este c este de y luego aquí arriba les
voy a poner a f g y h estoy usando
letras minúsculas para nombrar los
ángulos vale entonces entonces tenemos
que quede es igual a a d es igual a a
porque son opuestos por el vértice luego
a es igual a igual a porque son ángulos
correspondientes y es igual a h porque
son ángulos opuestos por el vértice vale
pero eso lo que nos permite deducir es
es igual a igual a h y a eso se les
conoce a eso se le conoce como ángulos
alternos internos alternos
alternos internos
internos tiene mucho sentido verdad
porque están aquí en el interior y son
alternos o sea no es este con este si no
es este con este de acá entonces decimos
que los ángulos alternos internos en una
pareja de rectas paralelas con una
transversal son iguales otra vez no te
tienes que aprender estas definiciones
porque a lo mejor es memorizar demasiado
pero lo que sí es muy importante es que
recuerdes cómo se muestra que éste es
igual a este de acá simplemente los
ángulos correspondientes son iguales y
luego éste es igual a éste porque son
opuestos por el vértice bueno esto sería
para los ángulos azules y ya nada más
para terminar tendríamos algo muy
similar para los para los ángulos rosas
el ángulo c es congruente al ángulo b
bueno es las medidas
esta medida es igual a esta b es igual a
efe porque son ángulos correspondientes
y finalmente f es igual a g porque son
opuestos por el vértice bueno vamos a
dejarle hasta aquí